[Music]  yes sophie Turner and clear eyes at  Jonathan van Ness head a total moment  backstage at the MTV Video Music Awards  and only a tease cameras were there to  capture it in case you forgot jvn is  such a big G ot fan he had his own web  series inspired by the HBO hit where  [Music]  third Emmy I'm so excited I think Emmy  voting ends on Thursday we've been  nominated three times and you're the  thing I could end up being the Susan  Lucci of a short-form Bridey series  short and that's fine because I love her  I love Game of Thrones and here at any  voter they go get it  yes now while Jonathan waits to see if  he'll pick up a little Emmy gold come  September Sophie got to get her hands on  her hubby's new hardware after the Jonas  Brothers won for Best Pop video at the  VMAs  [Music]